alo cho các bạn
anh alo
Xin chào bạn
ờ ờ nay mình còn sớm thành thổ tâm sự
một tí à
Ừ rồi thì ở công ty mình vừa bảo một tin
mình cảm thấy khá là cậu đến bây giờ
mình vẫn khá là sóc yêu cầu
công ty mình vừa có người bị tai nạn ở
vụ tai nạn
chị đấy trẻ bị tai nạn xe
em và
nói chung là đến rồi thì tất cả mọi
người vẫn đang hi vọng kiểu điều tốt
nhất cho chị ấy thôi
công ty và kết hợp với quản trị đầy cũng
ở ở
trong
miền Nam nên là thành ra là mãi đến hôm
trước mà em hôm trước thì khi mà công ty
thôi đi
đi tìm Team Building đi du lịch thì mình
mới kiểu mới cắt chữ lần đầu và mang
xuống cũng mới biết sự
hiện diện của chị đấy tiểu
mới gặp một lần mà cũng chưa biết được
là sau sẽ
sau sẽ còn gặp lại nữa không Nhưng mà
khi mà nghe
ở chỗ nghe một người kia đột nhiên hiểu
mình mình mới quen cũng nói chúng vào
hiểu Gần đi ở đang mọi thứ đang rất bình
thường được nghiên nghĩ việc là người ta
có một vấn đề gì đó như thế
a và có thể chọn trễ mình sẽ kiểu
trong là tôi không muốn nói gì nên đổi
bây giờ nhưng mà lấy chỗ nào nghe mình
cái đấy thì tôi mới thấy ra kiểu Cuộc
sống mọi thứ nó đôi khi nó quá ngắn ngủi
dù mình thường anh nói cái câu Tôi
thường này nói câu này nó Cuộc sống quá
ngắn ngủi cho những lại nhân cho những
chờ đợi
khi đôi khi béo cứ ngại cái gì đó nhưng
mấy ông không hề sống kiểu
à Cậu
sợ mà cái gì đói bình thường luôn sợ rất
nhiều thứ
không đến nỗi là mình không thực sự sống
à mình mình có phải mình phải có bỏ qua
những cái kiểu ngại ngùng Bỏ qua những
cái chỗ ở
gì đó đúng không ạ Mình Lười giống như
bạn kia cũng đang nói ngủ nhiều hay gì
đó đúng ạ ví dụ nha ví dụ
Hà Nội thấp Tôi không biết mấy ông như
thế nào nhưng mà tôi ở trong nhà nhiều
nhưng mà về các bạn thì tôi vẫn trải
nghiệm cuộc sống có khi là nhiều hơn tới
tôi tớ nghĩa là nhiều hơn cho nhiều
người kiểu dạng là
trải nghiệm ở đây không phải là kiểu ra
ngoài nhiều mà là mà là không ngại thay
đổi không ngại thử cái mới
em thử cái mới đây không phải mỗi đồ ăn
mới mà là gặp mẹ con người mới có những
kiểu những cuộc trò chuyện mới và Vân sở
thích mới cái gì đó
Ừ chứ không Nói chung là đại khái gần
như là là
khi những người xung quanh tôi thấy đi
Tôi thay đổi rất nhiều thay đổi cách rất
nhanh bởi vì ở trong một khoảng tầm chỉ
trong mấy mấy ông Tôi từng nói với ông
rồi đó là kiểu
mấy ông xem video đầu tiên thôi dậy
chẳng hạn so video bây giờ nóng trên nửa
năm thôi thì mày ông ở thấy sự khác biệt
rõ ràng cách nói chuyện mọi thứ đúng
không ạ
em còn mấy ông thì đôi khi làm mấy ông
nhìn lại mình nửa năm xong rồi năm thì
mới Ông thấy đã có tiền chuyện gì đã có
những cái gì thay đổi từ sự nghiệp
tiểu học hành tình cảm sức khỏe với Vân
hôm nay nó có những cái tiến triển gì
rồi người ông có thể tự Anh dán lại bản
thân mình không ạ
học thêm cái mới ít đúng thực sự là thời
gian
ở thời gian chơi đôi khi còn thiếu thời
gian ngủ tràn thiếu
ờ ờ và thời gian học thêm cái mới thì
thì cá nhân mình thì mai là mình vẫn à
mình vỡ vừa làm vừa học và chịu khó theo
dõi vài cái và nó thông báo mình liên
tục từ t ram thông đường Email ở mình
thường xuyên cập nhật thêm một vài cái
mới mua vé mới tới khi mà
Anh
chưa Còn về cơ bản thì nhiều anh em
trong công ty thì thì đang bị chạy gần
như bị kiểu dạng là công ty tôi không đi
sao đắt nên thành ra là vẫn đang thiếu
người thì ra là gì
xin nghỉ việc nó sẽ bị dồn đấy
tôi Tuy không phải nỗi rồi Mức là ngày
nào cũng chẳng biết like công ty thôi
Không có một thứ sự có một cái khái niệm
nào deride rồi à cơ dao việc xong rồi
anh em cứ làm là mua xong thì việc khác
kiểu kiểu thế Có nhiều việc thôi nhưng
mà không bị gì hết like gì cả nhưng mà
nhưng mà cũng khiến cho anh em kiểu dạng
này thường dặn là nếu mà thực sự làm thì
làm tới ngày luôn hiểu bởi vì không ngờ
hết việc và cũng cũng như là khi mà anh
em có thời gian rảnh thì anh em không
muốn ngồi máy tính để ngồi ngồi làm việc
mấy nữa mà anh em sẽ kiểu nói chung là
làm việc khác
Ừ mẹ nghe ở trong công ty tôi thở ra đều
hướng nội chủ yếu nên thành ra cũng
không hẳn lại ra bên ngoài tận hưởng
cuộc sống đâu có khái niệm đấy vẫn ở
trong nhà vẫn ngồi máy mà thật ra là
người làm việc khác không phải ngồi ngồi
học hay ngồi làm làm công việc thôi
nhưng nói chung à cái việc học tài liệu
thì
tôi thấy à cầu
anh nói chung là nhiều người rồi giống
như mấy ông ấy mấy ông kia dạng đi làm
xong thì mới ông kiểu thời gian rảnh thì
thì đôi khi mấy ông sẽ được giải trí hơn
là nhiều chỗ củng cố thêm kiến thức đúng
không ạ ạ
Ừ cái này là do tùy tìm được người có
người cảm thấy là Củng cố thêm kiến thức
thấy mệt mỏi có người lại thấy thú vị cá
nhân tôi thì thấy cũng cố thêm kiến thức
thì nó khá thú vị nhưng
gì để mà nói chính xác thì tôi không
dành theo kiểu là nhiều người thì sẽ
kiểu tự
v-app Ừ cũng đúng và kiểu quen thành
thói quen cũng đúng là kiểu một ngày sẽ
dành thời gian ra đọc sách hay nghiên
cứu cái gì đó 30 phút mỗi ngày chẳng hạn
tôi không có khái niệm đấy nghĩa nói
chung vào thời gian nào mà kiểu rảnh thì
và cảm thấy tự nhiên nó có thông báo đấy
tự nhiên thông báo thôi mình mình đọc
thôi nghĩa đọc vào mọi lúc có thể chứ
không quan trọng mà ngồi bấm rồi Cơn
đúng giờ này mình sẽ đọc file thường 30
phút Hãy giúp tôi không như thế
nó nó
ngoài việc là thoải mái theo kiểu thoải
mái cả thời gian thoải mái giờ giấc nó
sẽ kiểu nó không có một cái lịch trình
hiểu cụ thể cả cũng may ở kiểu mình đang
làm mà không làm tại nhà đang làm ngày
này có không thể nổ bắt buộc vậy đúng
giờ các thứ lắm cùng lắm là đúng mỗi giờ
đi dạy cho mấy ông này ạ
không ạ bản chất lần chất là chắc chắn
là ông không nhận ra lại chỗ rồi ông
chắc chắn nó kiểu gì sẽ có kiểu sự thay
đổi nhưng quan trọng thấy thay đổi để nó
có nhiều ý thôi đúng không ạ ạ
hay nói mấy ông nhà máy ông hang ngại
thay đổi làm bé ông hay nghĩ rằng nhà Ôi
bây giờ giả sử mình thay đổi một cái này
cái kia thì mình sẽ phải đánh đổi khá
nhiều thứ nhưng mà không hề cân nhắc
công việc cái giá mà khi mà mình không
thay đổi đúng ạ Khi mà mình không thay
đổi thì đôi khi là
nữa là có khiếu phát chán rồi trở lại
với tôi trẻ tuổi trẻ mình lên kiểu trải
nghiệm nhiều Tôi cũng trải nghiệm nhiều
Tôi cũng ra xử giả sử như mấy ông thấy
thế là tôi dậy cũng đúng cho 15 tầm tầm
đấy thì tôi không dạy nữa thôi không xẩy
qua livestream cảnh này nữa mà tôi sẽ đi
dạy ngoài này chẳng hạn Đông ạ
sau đó thì tôi sẽ cậu làm việc khác gì
đó mày ông cạn về cá nhân tôi cũng tôi
không nói tôi tôi trực gọi nhỉ Nó chưa
từng nói Tôi ở tấm gương sáng đúng ạ
nhưng tôi bảo là tôi tiền bối và mày ông
hoàn toàn thế thấy là ừ ý giao thì cái
hướng hướng đi của tôi có vẻ ạ gọi là có
một cái tư duy gì đó ổn để mấy ông có
thể tham khảo không phải báo trước nghe
tôi không thích kiểu đã hồi trưa đã từng
có một vài người chỗ gọi dùng từ những
mẫu uống đúng ở người đấy nói ngưỡng mộ
nhưng mà bị ngưỡng mộ những cái Hả Quá
được cậu cố bắt chước gần như biến thành
một bản sao của tôi
khi dùng đúng nghĩa là như thế luôn đấy
bởi vì à Đến cả câu nói đùa thôi hay đùa
ông mẹ mất trước ạ Anh cười như thế Thực
ra là nó không thể Hay để ạ Khi mà mình
cố là một loại sao người khác đúng ạ Nó
sẽ hiểu không tốt đúng không ạ Chúng ta
nên là kiểu
chúng ta lên là phiên bản hoàn thiện
phiên bản ổn hơn của chính mình mỗi ngày
chứ không phải là phiên bản có bất kỳ ai
cả Ai có ưu và nhược của họ không ạ Và
A và kiểu dáng gần như là mấy ông không
không thể bắt chước một người đó hoàn
toàn được với ông chiều rõ bản thân mình
Nếu không phải hiểu rõ bản thân mình
điểm mạnh điểm yếu và hơn mình rồi tự
mình cải thiện thôi chẳng phải mình đi
bắt chước người khác thấy khác về bề
ngoài vậy hào nhóm II vẫn trước người
đấy mình không thể biết được Họ trải qua
phải chạy phải trải qua những cái gì thì
được như thế nhưng không biết được rồi
đấy ông ạ
Ông Bà mình mà bắt chước họ giả sử giống
như mấy người giàu ấy Bây giờ tôi toàn
xem thường mấy ông tập chưa mấy ông thấy
mấy người kia rau ngạnh mấy ông cũng bắt
chước thì giờ khi họ Mấy ông không không
phải biết được là họ hoàn cảnh rắn họ
khác mình vào Vân làm sao mà có thể bắt
chước cử họ thì nó sẽ mặc định biển này
giàu không ạ nghe thấy mình cười không ạ
em dậy ngoài quay lại video Up lên cho
mọi người tham khảo thứ cái gì đó là hơi
khó vụ đấy mình cũng nghĩ vụ đấy nhưng
hơi khó
à vì thứ nhất là từ nước là cậu đứng yên
là mình sẽ không bỏ kênh này khi mình đi
dạy ở ngoài mình sẽ định là sẽ biến hàng
buổi chụp chiều chủ nhật hay một buổi gì
đó mình sẽ thường hay thông báo cụ thể
trước một vài hôm mà mình sẽ có
livestream cái gì đó họp để mà like cốt
hoặc là dạy một cái gì đó Nói chung là
cái kênh của mình hướng đến thử ta về
sau ngoài việc là chia sẻ cốt thì sẽ là
cái mình vẫn hướng đến là kiểu
Vì sao làm vlog nếu cậu là à mình sẽ
chia sẻ thêm nhiều trải nghiệm nữa theo
bắt nhìn của mình nếu mà Mấy ông thích
con nhìn của tôi Mình không thích nghe
từ nói chém gió gì gió thì sẽ thì tôi sẽ
hướng đi của lễ thậm chí biết đâu vì sao
thanh âm postcard hai cái gì đó Làm sao
để sẵn thế vì cá nhân tôi nghĩ à Ở Tôi
nghĩ là tôi cũng có Tùy trẻ mặt còn non
nữa Nhà tôi nghĩa là tôi anh
chững chạc gọi dùng từ chững chạc so với
cùng lứa kiểu thế bởi vì hoàn cảnh ép
tôi phải thay đổi sớm dùng từ như thế
hướng cho từ giờ đến tháng 10 sẽ dạy khá
nhiều thứ để mà cho gần như là những cái
gì mà tôi thể dậy được thì tôi sẽ cố dậy
thì gần như là khi mà đến khi mà tôi
không không dạy kiểu thường xuyên nữa
thì mấy ông cũng đủ lượng kiến thức để
mà Mấy ông đi làm được rồi thì thực ra
cũng không cần lấy dậy thì mấy nữa cái
thằng Thế cùng ngắm những cái buổi mà
tôi sẽ like cốt là gần như là để mình
ông có thể giao thể ngồi cùng thảo luận
cùng xem xem mà ạ Cái ý tưởng cũng giờ
có thể gần như là lập trình đôi nhé mẹ
ông hoàn toàn thể góp ý cùng tôi cùng
nghĩ cái một bài toán một vấn đề gì đó
ngồi làm cùng hướng đến mong và tội mong
thế nghĩa là đến cái ra đấy thì mấy ông
đều hiểu qua về lập trình có một cách
tương đối ổn rồi đề mà lập trình được
chứ không phải
chứ không phải cần chờ tôi dậy kiểu cầm
tay chỉ lỗi nữa lúc đấy gần như là mấy
ông mọc đồ lông đủ cánh để bay hết rồi
đúng ạ
chắn à Người ta trả tiền mình thì nó đỡ
buồn ông nghĩa về bản quyền mà chắc là
không không thể làm mà ghi lại để mà
chưa trả cho bé uống được Và Thở Ra dạy
ở ngoài tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ dậy theo kiểu
là cũng dậy đúng như ở dạy cho mấy ông
thôi nên nên nó cũng chả khác thì mấy
Vì thế tôi dậy rồi Tôi định sáng bên FPT
dậy thì dậy Factor mà Thì tôi cũng dậy
trong mấy ông đúng kiểu thực facile lên
vô Junior nữa là số không khác gì mà ừ
và chính xác ở Tôi sinh năm 97 nói tôi
cứ để ở trên
trên cầu mô tả là 96 thì tôi sinh tháng
em nghe từ ông em 96 Bách Khoa nghe nó
có ai mà có rùa Tôi cũng không phải Học
với khoa học cao đẳng nghề Bách Khoa
mình hôm nay mình bắt đầu lại ngồi quay
lại cái bài toán hôm trước đúng ạ nó hôm
trước đã đăng bài tao thử thử rồi
cho mình xem lại nha em nhiều không ạ
Ừ vậy thì thôi Tắt bớt đèn
có một loạt bài rồi đúng
à à ngọt không
ở đây Company ra
công ty trong trường hợp này nó là ờ ờ
nun Đông ạ Mình sẽ mình xem ở đây có lại
liên quan đến ở trong vị suốt view nó cụ
thể là trong component Vân like mình sẽ
phải sợ lại không vấn
anh bởi vì ở trong rừng có bài đăng hôm
trước là bài đăng không có company
em có bay năng không có money money ID
do trống này đúng ạ Có đúng một bài đăng
này không có thì ra là mình sẽ phải sửa
lại cốt mình sẽ sửa lại ở đây như này
còn phân này tốt này vì cho đầy object
là có thể nun lại thấy sau A
và tiếp theo đây nó báo là trong trường
hợp có vấn Y không có logo à không có
Company thì không thể ra logo đúng ạ thì
mình sẽ
em sửa lại bên A
ở bên phim này
Ừ cái này sẽ có
suốt ngày kia tôi tạo Linh
trong trường hợp mà nếu mà không có như
này thì mình thường mình có thể để là
kiểu à
I accept theo cả là nếu không có
Ừ nếu có access
a
Company ngay
Ừ thì mình mấy in ra
ở đây một cách ông có thể dùng arsenal
arsenal tấn hai chỗ ngày và hiển thị ra
gạch ít này tôi Nghĩa không nên nên kiểu
như hai thì nó sẽ hợp lý hơn
rồi thì mình sẽ trả về ở đây sẽ là hỏi
chấm dứt Trinh nữa có thì chuyển vào chỗ
trống sẽ là
lại một vài một vài cái về kiểu dạng là
cho phép luôn là một vài chỗ này nha
mình sẽ phải sửa lại code một tí không ạ
sẽ là trong trường hợp này nó sẽ rồi trả
về được phép trả với trống này
khi trở về luôn không ạ
à à
thì nó sẽ ra nha
Em tải cái ba năng không có Company tôi
nghĩa thế
em ở đâu không phải có muốn nhiều hay
thổ là nhiều nhé
gì hôm sao để tạo mình như thế đây sẽ là
cơ servo thứ vào mắt đằng sau đấy thị ra
một cái Trần Hồ Chí minh họa
nào à
a cho tôi đang định bảo là mình sẽ hiển
thị ra thêm một vài thông tin nữa Từ cái
á
Cho xem con thì địa được gì à
gì đâu cũng khá hay nóng
Thế là mất công để bấm vào như này thì
cá nhân tôi thấy thực ra là cái này để
làm giao diện cho đẹp nhưng thực ra trải
nghiệm người dùng có thể tệ với người
dùng thực sự là nếu mà nó kêu ít thông
tin thế này thả hiển thị luôn cái thông
tin location ở ngay dưới này nó sẽ ổn
hơn thay vì kiểu bất lực bắt người dùng
phải bấm vào mày không hiểu được không ạ
nhưng mà
có tk người dùng có thể filter cái này
mà
vì tôi nghĩa là thôi Tại tôi sẽ tạm bỏ
cái á không trong cái bôi trách này tôi
đang tôi tôi biết về cái
Java Suite cái kia là web Token à Nhưng
mà tôi ấp úng
ở Hà Nội xin nghỉ
ở season
ở nhà tôi không dùng Cái đấy trong cái
trong trường hợp này
dùng luôn đấy chứ không phải hơ vơ Mọi
việc hôm trước tôi có đề cập với bởi
việc nếu em thường là người dùng bây giờ
hướng đến là có dùng điện thoại nhiều
còn nếu mà em làm khô vợ ấy thì người
dùng không hiểu để mà cậu Ấn tay vào giữ
để mà nó biến vu vơ đâu Kiểu gì Anh
không nghĩ là nên hiển thị ra thẳng luôn
không cần mập mờ thế không
thẳng luôn đã nóng có cái gì đâu không ạ
nhìn thật thằng luôn ở bên mình sẽ hiển
thị ra nằm ở đâu nhỉ Ở đâu cho hợp lý
bây giờ
- class này
vì tôi nghĩa là có thể đẩy nó ở góc bên
trên là thế
Lê Ngọc Bình trên bên phải
A là
cho tất cả hai sánh
anh xóa sử về điện
ừ ừ
Ừ tại vì hồi trước ở Tôi định kiểu hiển
thị gia ở viện K dixon đấy là thành phần
là
whiteman cái mô tả ngắn gọn qua ở của
cái
thế này Nhưng mà thực là cái đi qua mình
đấy nó là Tech nó sẽ rất là dài nên anh
là tôi nghĩa là tổng sự như này nhanh
ở Hà Nội thì chị ra t
Ừ Ừ chắc thế này thôi Có thể bấm mà có
thể bấm vào cái đây để nhảy đến Company
Nhưng cái đấy sẽ sửa sao tạm thời là anh
chưa có
Em hãy tôi nghĩa có thể thêm ở ngay đoạn
này mình sẽ có một cái tôi đ u Cái đấy
là là
hồ sơ đồ này
đua nhưng không có thể làm tắt như này
bố mẹ tôi hồi trước tôi thường làm bắp
khi bé trong trường hợp mà Mấy ông làm
mà làm nhiều có cậu dạng là làm ở công
ty nhiều người không ạ sẽ kiểu tôi đủ
Vì sao nó thì thêm cả cong dụ đó vì danh
của bản thân chẳng hạn như thế như này
cái này để làm gì Để mỗi lần mình gõ
thodu cái cảnh như này
chi tiết
Ừ
cái tôi bị tắm rồi
gì mà lạ vậy
à à
ai chở ngay
số xổ sau đó thì để mấy ông Chỉnh lại
màu này thì rất là hai ông có thể chỉ
lại cái mẫu hỏi sau
Ừ tôi có thể phi to gọi này edit photo
này hồi chiều tôi bảo để Long nó sẽ có
màu đỏ ấy không thể sửa lại cái này anh
mới dụ chịu tim là lời cản lưu lại này
em có những sẽ thấy ra cho mình sẽ Peter
theo cậu phối chưa tin nữa nó thì sẽ có
một túi Ru nó nằm ở file nào
có bao nhiêu này
a tp-store mà tôi đang dùng mạng mèo edu
Ừ để ông ấy dụ được
edit link rồi nhãn
a company
Anh nói vậy thôi Không làm nghe này sẽ
da xịn
thường mà mày không phải ghi chú thích
đã xong với ông ấy cậu
Có mấy kiểu dạng gile comment nhé sẽ
hiểu ngay à
à Tôi đang hơi khó chịu Comment này
comment này tự nhiên nó đẩy đây thay vì
đây giống như kiểu hội làm pp Thôi kệ
không sao đóng mở này vẫn được là được
cái tôi đô này có sẵn của pastore
hỗ trợ mấy ông thấy ngon không tự nhiên
ngon rồi với cốt của mẹ làm gì có điều
đấy Alo không biết được chắc
với cốt của mấy ông kiểu gì chẳng có một
cái Lucky nào đó nhưng mà mail phải cài
thêm đúng không Cái này có sẵn
Có khi nào chồng kiểu ra Tùng minh dễ
hiểu về sau mày Ông mở kẹp em lên để mà
xem có vấn đề gì đó không Khi mà cốt của
ông được kiểm tra
anh như này các thứ thứ đúng không ạ cho
đến kiểu kiểm tra tôi đô này kiểm tra
hít rồi trật Amino bên trong này Đây mới
là một ID thật sự đúng không ạ
cho sự 53 cái Editor vest AA
Nghe ca nhạc à
Ừ ừ mẹ ngồi chém gió quên xử mất cái
Bình Định nói rồi à mình sẽ hiển thị
toàn bộ các
location ở ở bên này không ạ location
bạn trong trường hợp này location ở đây
tôi sẽ dùng là city của chính năng
Porsche trưng bày của thằng Company toàn
bộ City bỏ qua đi city có đi chứ
toàn bộ xì tin
à à
trình duyệt à Xin cho tôi thứ cả tôi
không hẳn thích Chrome mà chả qua là
đồng bộ sang muối tài khoản Google phải
dùng thôi người mình lưu lại trong tài
khoản Cô rất nhiều thứ chứ thực ra không
hẳn thích à Trông đâu hết thì ta nó nhẹ
nhanh hơn thật đấy nhưng mà bây giờ nó
không đồng bộ
ừ ừ
Đã lâu rồi k Tôi rất thích muốn có một
hệ sinh thái tôi chỉ cắm đầu ở hệ sinh
thái đấy giống như kiểu gogo2 của
Microsoft hay của Huawei
chẳng hạn thế hoặc thỏa thuận giữa
Xiaomi
à Mà hồi trước và kiểu
nói trước là từng thích cả Nokia để ngăn
nhưng Nokia chết rồi
Ừ nhưng mà còn là Samsung nữa cả Apple
Tôi không thích cho dù à
em cho dù là tôi đang định mua iPhone để
mà nói chung à Thử trải nghiệm cả hai hệ
điều hành cùng một lúc cho nó cho nó kêu
mình mình nhìn được treo nhiều góc nhìn
thấy thích thì nó không ăn thích lắm
nhưng mà còn Samsung sẽ làm tốt không ờ
Ừ anh đang nói gì
Tôi sẽ đầu tiên thì tôi sẽ chỉ mấy ông
cách là có tiên mình sẽ hiển thị toàn bộ
các City ở đây cho kiểu chọn tích tích
ngay đúng không Thi thì cái ở đây mình
cần làm Đó là theo theo tôi Theo tôi
nghĩ thì nó
anh có hai hướng để mình làm thì chị ra
cái ở đây một cái là sẽ
một cái là mình sẽ thoát ra ngay từ khi
mình vào cái trang này mình sẽ dùng tfp
hiển thị ra tất cả các cái mình đã lắp
đấy Các nghĩ cái cái nhất thứ hai là tôi
nghĩ là
em gà trang ngày thử tải nó nhanh Thôi
mình không làm không cần lấy lỗi rằng
phức tạp và tất cả là mà áo rách và tôi
muốn hạn chế cái Trang ở bên ở bên mình
kể âm lịch cần cả pro mà kết hợp với
Iraq đã dùng cốt lõi lấy chồng nó dài
trong xấu với Nghĩa đoạn này tôi nghĩ là
tôi sẽ làm phần hết vòng TP em về cơ bản
thì nó Tôi nghĩ là nó không nặng nề thế
Gà có thể đấy Bây giờ đang ngồi loạt ở
tận 2 giây ở trên máy cá nhân local thì
chả có thể nó sẽ nặn thật là thử xem
vietlott time tầm 2 giây đúng ạ Vừa nãy
lúc mà lần đầu lót thì sẽ ra tận 3,8
giây mà kết hợp với loa thêm vài cái nữa
Ừ xuống nghĩa là lên dẫn bún dây chẳng
hạn thì đi sau đó thì nếu mà là đẩy lên
mạng thì thuộc gì nó sẽ lên một cộng hai
dây 1 đến 2 giây nữa 6 giây ở lót một
cái trang này cho dù trang này chả có
cái thông tin gì cả Ừ nếu mà thế thì
công nhận là Trang lại nói sự rất là
nặng thật
thì tôi nghĩa sẽ phải hiển thị cái này
bằng A Di Đà
Ừ để tôi tí nhá Tàu cơ thủ chuối làm
thuần đã nha hiệu xanh nhạt
khi vào trang này đúng ạ tôi tạm tắt đi
này tiền mà khi vào cái trang âm lịch
cần này mình sẽ lót
hôm Tết Index Đúng chưa Nguyễn Thị Diệp
akinator đúng không Rồi thì bây giờ
trong trường hợp này mình muốn lấy toàn
bộ City ạ
Ừ
từ bài đăng này mình sẽ lấy toàn bộ City
Từ Ghost sau đó thì lọc Trung nó distant
nó sẽ
phó sửa đây này
sau đó đi sân lọc Trung đó sau đó mình
sẽ ghét thật đấy
anh ở đây thôi Cái this tin thì nó dùng
hàm có sẵn của thằng Mai queo nhưng mà
nhưng mà mấy ông sẽ thấy một sự sự thật
là rõ ra ngoài Hà Nội Hồ Chí Minh này nó
vẫn lọc trùng mấy thằng này đúng ạ Tôi
nghĩ là có thể là chị có mỗi Surf City ở
đây chị đã đủ rồi sau đó thì mình sẽ
phải lọc Chung bằng pp để mình sẽ
Ẩm Thực sự nó là trùng chứ không phải là
kiểu nó sẽ là như nào sẽ ở đây Tôi lấy
ra được City ở đây nhưng mà tôi vẫn sẽ
có một cái Android city nha này ạ chẳng
hạn thế
ạ sau đó tôi chạy vòng lặp City ở đây
đoạn này nếu mà viết ngắn hơn và đoạn
này cho nó biến thành Chắc chắn là chỉ
có suýt Tây anh theo kiểu nhé Đây để tôi
thử đài đây đây ở đây cho mấy ông dễ
hình dung nhé
em giả sử Giả sử ngày đúng không Nếu mà
tôi lấy xe lách mỗi City và tôi ghét
ngay đúng không khi mấy ông sẽ thấy là
nó sẽ bản chất nó sẽ trả về một cô gái
chân và một câu đấy Sân đấy phải gọi đến
thêm một thằng một lần nữa cho đến City
gặp today's rồi nha
trò chơi nhà mà ông sẽ phải chờ đến CT
thì mới lấy được Hà Nội chẳng ạ nhưng mà
đến bằng cách viết của tôi nó sẽ thay
đổi tôi thường này viết nó sẽ kiểu ngay
lúc phẳng như ảnh cái này rất là xịn ở
điểm là nó vua Nó vừa ghét nó vừa nó vừa
select mỗi City Và thậm chí là nó còn
biến thằng này thành một thằng khác cậu
là dễ lấy dễ lấy hơn dễ lấy thằng City
hơn
anh
không Không cần phải gọi đến thuộc tính
CT nữa vẫn lấy được ai
Vì sao để cho dễ hình dung hơn tôi nghĩ
à dùng vòng lặp có ích như thế này cho
mấy ông dễ mừng tượng hơn đi à
tôi thử D hàng City ở đây nha em vừa rồi
là tôi tạm
xe bỏ thằng lắc này tôi có select City ở
đúng chứ
A và ghét ngày Đúng không Đúng không
Ừ nếu mà trong trường hợp này tôi gửi
d-city mình cũng sẽ thấy là thằng City
là phải gọi đến city rồi gọi đến city
rồi nữa mà trông rất buồn cười mình lấy
được cụ thể hà nội đối ngoại đúng không
ạ
Ừ đấy thậm chí có nhiều bạn ở có thể làm
tắt được như này Ờ thì cũng nó vẫn là
phải gọi đến City như thường thôi vẫn sẽ
phải gọi City Hay mày lấy được Hà Nội
đúng không ạ Hay vì như thế Tôi có hàm
thật thì con tắt hơn nó sẽ như này thì
tôi chỉ cần gọi City nhưng mà lấy được
Hà Nội rồi Cái này sẽ trả về cái mảng
chữa chứ sao là Collection có đặc trưng
trứng khỏe mạnh nhờ Collagen chỉ chứa
mỗi giá trị của City hôi
tiện hơn nó xịn hơn rất nhiều và trong
trường hợp này
mình sẽ
cách của tôi thường hay là nó Kiều
Ừ ông
bản chất là cái này mình sẽ làm như sau
mình sẽ chỗ ở mà chắc là City này Nhưng
mà ông thấy có cả Hà Nội phải Hồ Chí
Minh như này đúng không ạ Mình sẽ
có phải cậu
có phải cẩu expro bìa nó để biến nó
thành mảng kiểu Nga đã
city nha à
xe tải sau đó thì mình mấy kiểu
Ừ mình cắt nhau bởi dấu phẩy không ạ mất
nhau dấu phẩy sau đó đây mình sẽ kiểu
I know the face nhưng ở đây thừa các dấu
cách này
vì vậy có cách đi đấy Sau đó mình sẽ làm
gì mình sẽ truyền từng thằng giá trị này
vào trong cái màng ngay sau đó thì mình
ở đây unique thêm Lộc chung để một cách
1 cách nữa đó là ông Ông kiểm tra
anh chạy phòng lập
anh ở đây như thế này
thử nhé ICT này bằng remote này
hình như ở cái này nó không đọc không hỗ
trợ Lập Trung đúng rồi nó không hỗ trợ
lập chung Ừ như thế Tôi phải chưa Cái
này vậy
fort này Play
sau đó mình kiểm tra ít
ờ ờ
Ừ nếu mà không nằm trong
Ừ thôi Đôi khi tôi không nhớ được cả
thằng nào thằng kiểm tra thằng nào trong
thằng nào đâu
anh ở đây đây ai kiểm tra có tốt tạo cho
mày không Nếu mà không có thì mình sẽ
truyền hàng đấy vào này này
các bạn này mấy ông để dễ hiểu hơn thì
mới ông cái hình dung được là tôi chỉ
tôi đang truyền từng giá trị trong kể
chuyện đựng tiền
thì mình sẽ kiểm tra xem mà nó đã tồn
tại trong mạng này chưa Nếu chưa thì
mình truyền mà thôi
thì nó sẽ chỉ thế nào với ai à
em có ra cả thằng không có gì với có
trường hợp nào nên thì để mình loại bỏ
chủ nhật luôn thì mình sẽ cho ít
anh em tin ở đây đúng không
Ừ nếu mà kiểu không trống
Ừ hình như này à
à à
à à à à Tôi thường ai kiểm tra như thế
này tôi khuyên mấy ông ấy đó là mình hôm
trước tôi đọc một cái Có 2 cách để mở
mình ông cốt 11 mấy ông Cư kiểm tra
trường hợp Đúng rồi mấy ông thực hiện
đúng kiểu như này
ở đây là trường hợp đúng thì mới thực
hiện có của mấy ông thế này thời ga nó
sẽ bị kiểu mì Ông thấy à ít à Xong rồi
bên trong này cho bên trong rồi bên
trong này như thế này nó sẽ trải nghiệm
người dùng rất là tệ trong trường hợp
này thì thay vì như thế thì tôi tôi
nghĩa tôi đọc được thì nó là kiểu Return
sớm nghĩa là mình sẽ trả về tất cả cái
kết quả sai trước đã để mà Thế cuối nó
sẽ luôn Chạy được thay vì mình tốn quá
nhiều cái chỗ xử lý phức kiểu dạng là
vòng lòng vòng lặp ai cơ chứ im ipf ở
bên trong nó kiểu bị lồng nhau Nó sẽ
kiểu thành kim tự tháp đấy à không Này Ừ
kiểu cỡ thế nó sẽ cho Cốt nó sẽ rất khó
đọc trong trường hợp nếu mà trống như
này mình sẽ continue bỏ qua này tương tự
Thế chồng tưởng mày mình cũng thấy thế
nếu mà nếu mà đã tồn tại rồi mình sẽ con
tin đi bỏ qua chẳng hạn như thế
có phải nó sẽ rất là nhẹ được Kiểu đó
nhìn cốt mình sẽ từng minh hơn cậu như
thế mình đỡ vậy
Ừ thì toàn bộ những cái dưới sẽ trường
hợp đúng không ạ
anh giải trí
anh anh thủ ngắm nào thế có cả 2 màn
hình mày không chỉ được ngắm một màn
hình thôi
thì tại sao này đó
nó có kiểu trong trường hợp đó chống lại
bỏ qua rồi em bây giờ chắc chắn nó sẽ
chỉ có ra được này sau đúng ạ ok
thì
mình sẽ truyền Galaxy Ti này
Ê mấy ông thể cái cốt của tôi bạn sẽ thế
cái tốt của tôi nó sẽ kiểu đặt tên biến
này xong rồi việc ở đoạn cốt này nó là
xử lý một đoạn sau đó Liên cách ra cái
đoạn này định xử lý Gian Khác với cách
ra đến thằng cuối ngày ông thấy tự nhiên
không phải hướng nghe tôi tự nhiên thừa
hẳn một cái dấu enter ở đây làm gì đâu
mà ông thấy Cốt nó sẽ khá tiền Minh đoạn
này xử lý với nhau liền với nhau này
đoạn này xử liền với nhau loãng ở cổ
Đoạn này để in ra này
ok à
City cũng được ở Huy đặt tên nó ICT để
mà để mà tối hiểu được là nó không phải
lấy từ tao bầy
Ê mấy ông để ý thì cách đặt tên cốt của
tôi sẽ là tùy ở cái này xuống nhiều vào
đây nó bản chất là nói xuống nhiều như
tôi phải ghi cho AB bằng trước thể hiểu
được mà Thằng này nó ở đây không phải
Collection Bởi vì nếu của Leesin mình sẽ
gọi mình sẽ hiểu nó ra đối tượng mình sẽ
gọi thì cậu dạng đối tượng còn Android
thì mới nhiên mình sẽ xử lý như kiểu với
Android thôi ông ạ Bây giờ nó cả hai đều
chạy vòng vo for được nhưng mà rõ ra mà
một hàng ngày đối tượng thì mình sẽ gọi
kiểu là con thỏ chuyển sang cùng một
hàng thì gọi theo cửa Đây đúng ạ sử dụng
cái cái cái dạng mảnh không ạ
ông có hiểu tôi đang nói gì Không nhưng
mà tôi nghĩa là tôi đang chia sẻ cái mà
thứ mà nhớ ra xử mà giả sử mà chúng yêu
mà nghe được một cái đấy thì xuất sản
cốt của họ cải thiện tôi nghĩa sẽ cải
thiện đáng kể
a real kiểu chữa do tự nghĩ trường hợp
đấy ông ạ Bây giờ mình nghĩ
Giá mà hồi đấy Có ai nói mình mới vụ đấy
này mình tự mò
cá nhân tôi Tôi nghĩ là thế đấy
tôi bảo thì mình sẽ à sẽ để kiểu à
ngày đấy nhá
chủ đề kiểu dạng là
à à
ừ ừ
ở đây là One Piece
đ.d fanpage ê
anh
rồi chấm location ở
ạ sau đó thì ở đây Đổ dưới sẽ là
ô ô
thì mình sẽ chạy vòng lặp vậy mà in từng
cái label ra đúng nhỉ từng cái đít cách
bóp thì phải đúng nhỉ tạo lên cái đít
nữa thì sẽ rõ
Ừ ừ đúng rồi
anh Hải thì mình sẽ chạy vòng vo phối
kiểu đây
cách cả nhà đông ạ sau đó thì mình chỉ
được đơn giản in từ người City ở đây
thôi
à à
mấy ông thấy là ở đây có một cái đó là ở
đó là có một sự thật đấy
Đó là ờ
cho cái setting ở thời gian nào ít Thay
đổi cái ông thấy là tui tải lại xa mãi
như lần nữa thử k-city này thường ít
thay đổi đúng ạ thì mình có thể lưu lại
danh sẽ City này
Anh thường là tôi sẽ lưu lại phải danh
sách City này
khi chúng ta thường này lưu lại với cái
Thanh Peter này
và đương nhiên ở mỗi khi mà mình Cập
nhật cập nhật Cái Cập nhật cái bài đăng
mình sẽ có thể kiểm tra lại danh city xe
mà nó có thay đổi gì không Mình Cập nhật
lại vào nó rồi mình sẽ lại kết quả lại
đều lại
lý do
cá nhân thì mình tôi nghĩ là mình nên
mình sẽ bắt cái sự kiện mà mỗi khi mà
cái xanh này
ở mỗi khi là thằng này cẩu
à à
Anh nhìn nghe khó chịu quá à
ở mỗi khi phải thằng này có kiểu thái
Đức cho update hoặc là Insert Vì sẽ lấy
city của nó rồi mình sẽ cập nhật vào
trong danh sách này và mình cách có lại
mình đi ngó lại trong vòng 30 ngày ạ sau
đó thì mặc định khi mình vào cái trang
fanpage này mình sẽ luôn lấy tư cách ra
thay vì mình gấu mình mình cứ phải mất
công người nhái thì tôi nghĩa cái đoạn
City này tôi sẽ cách có lại ok chưa thì
ở đây City mình sẽ lấy hơi của boss Nếu
là 11 là mấy ông có thể mất nó vào trong
Phúc ăn cho đâu để em một cách
à hay là gì
có ai làm mấy ông thể Vứt vào trong
Model như thế này
kết các thứ vào trong mua đồ để nó xem ở
đầu tiên thì bây giờ mình sẽ thử làm vụ
cách trước họ đã không ạ toàn bộ thông
tin này toàn bộ thử cái mạng này thì
mình sẽ làm là kết còn lại thì sẽ làm
theo cậu ngay à
không có forever nha hôm trước tới nó
rồi không nên là forever thì sẽ đặt tên
ở đây là à mình cái chi của nó thì lại
nên để nó là nó là theo kiểu là với nhớ
không lầm là khi này nên à mình nên tạo
một cái key năm để về sau mình dễ xoa dễ
hiểu mình dễ Xóa Hay vì mình cậu ghi vào
trong này
và tội mấy ông nhớ việc là tôi có tạo
tạo bàn con chích không nhỉ Đây có bạn
không thích này một kia ba lô này mình
sẽ thường là một là mình lưu lại trong
i5 Hay Là Mình lưu lại trong khi velu
như này để mình dễ hiểu
yêu cầu về sau mình sẽ xóa theo với
kintaru thì như thế
anh ở đây tôi nghĩa là sẽ có một bảng là
sẽ có một cái là
Season Season cách năm thì như thế Mình
lưu lại trong hệ thống các thứ thứ những
cái i5 Mình muốn để về sau mình sẽ xóa
theo cái chi đấy xoạc cách theo quy hiểu
không
Ai biết đâu về sau kiểu ông muốn xóa cái
cách này đi thì ông sẽ kiểu tìm thấy cái
năm đấy xóa chứ hạn chế là dùng cách
clear cache clear sẽ xóa toàn bộ cách
thức a nó không nên ở những dự án lớn
thì không nên làm thế
có ai Tôi sẽ tạo một cái
đây này
à à
khi họ đến hài
ạ sau đó thì ở đây là à make năm này Ừ
rồi system này là hệ thống không ạ Chị
sẽ cách khi này sinh năm này
hoặc cách qi năm tù ông đặt giờ tôi muốn
đặt tên chữ system mời lần trước phải mà
mình hiểu được là ngày liên quan đến bên
hệ thống
thì nó sẽ có một cái à
anh cách ghi nhạc
à à
cái điều này thằng Trung tâm nó dậy ông
ấy cái điều này
các
dự án thực tế mà giờ tùy từng nơi nó dậy
ông này còn nhiều ông đi làm được đấy
chứ chắc là được dạy mấy điều này
khi mở nhạc
thì mình sẽ đặt tên ở đây là
xì ting đúng không là tên như thế nào ạ
a filter City Peter location
đặt tên như nào cho từng Minh bây giờ
nhé fanpage location Onepiece
Ừ để tôi đang muốn nó là fanpage
the best location
xe bus
I got City Hull City
Ừ ừ đặt tên là location
đây đây bản chất đây là City thôi nên
thời gian mình không cần phải xem chữ
đâu cái chất được nữa City OST
a Future Past City
a What City
cả
ngày cũng được
ừ ừ
hơi khó chịu khi mày i5 nó nó lại là giá
trị giống hệt hiểu ngay nhưng mà
phải là để cho kiểu về sau i5 mình thay
đổi giá trị ở giữa mà để cho mình hiểu
được là có một thằng i5 này tồn tại để
về sau mình còn nhớ được à à Hồi trước
mình đặt kitten nó là như thế này để
mình sẽ xóa thì có tên như này chứ Cái
này gần như là nó là cô nó là hằng số
còn nhiều mình không mờ đổi thì ở đâu
nha Mình cần yêu mình không ngờ đội cái
này nó sẽ có hai khái niệm y nam và như
thế Chị cãi i5 về sau mình mới có thể
đổi được là những cái i5 ở kiểu dạng là
ví dụ Giả sử là về sau ông Hiện tại ông
đăng ký cấp và i5 là không ấy 12 gì đó
nó hạt amin cái gì đó về sau uống hai
đội được ký năm đấy con cái i5 này lại
còn như nó cố định
Anh không ngờ đổi có cả để mình hiểu
được à mình từng là tên tên kiểu ngày mà
mình sẽ xóa đi cậu nha
lái xe assistant về kỹ năng này như thế
này
a tiếp theo là mình sẽ lưu lại với bảo
rồi mặc định là lưu 30 ngày không ạ Mình
sẽ
ờ ờ ờ 60 60 nhân
sinh này
a slit Ơn Thánh ala City Ừ nó như này
à à
Ừ giờ mình bản chất là bây giờ mình gọi
mình
tại và lại trang này
thì tại sao phân nữa đấy
tại trang này nếu không thấy có quay đi
để lấy á
em lấy City đúng không Tại sao không nữa
anh mất rồi quay đi lấy City ở Đông ạ
Còn Chắc là bây giờ mình sẽ lấy từ cách
chọn cách đầu
cách mà nhỉ
Nhưng mà như tôi đã bảo thì bên mình sẽ
phải ạ
cho mình mình sẽ phải cậu sau khi mà mỗi
khi mà kẹo bài đăng thay đổi nghĩa là
update hoặc À in-shop thì mình sẽ
nhật lại cái cái cái key này mình sẽ
kiểm tra xem có tồn tại không Rồi mình
sẽ Cậu cập nhật lại cái đấy đúng không ạ
thì
Ừ thì đây mình sẽ làm gì sau mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ kiểm tra mình hôm trước có
bạn bảo tôi là
anh em làm cái đoạn ở
ba mẹ em off rô để kiểm tra xem à mỗi
khi nó
Ừ Nó kiểu cập nhật cái gì đó thì em off
rồi
mình nên dùng Fshare
nhờ server của thằng nào Theo ý hay mình
dùng Ving
Ê mày ông nhớ về cái đấy ông ạ Nó hai
cái khác nhau một cái là cậu lắng nghe
sự kiện của thằng ngày mỗi khi và cập
nhật thêm sửa xóa gì đó cần even là tạo
ra một cái độc lập theo kiểu là là mình
sẽ dám dám cho nó tôi nghĩa là tôi dùng
cái đó đâu có mình chuẩn có thằng nào
giao cho dễ hình dung đi
anh ở nhà rồi mình sẽ tạo một cái bóp
dầu ở đây đúng nó cho nó mặc định nó sẽ
có kiểu là khi mà thêm này cập nhật này
đi lên thì cái gì đó thì sẽ lắng nghe
những cái sự kiện đấy để mình làm thêm
ví dụ lịch sự khi mà người dùng mới đăng
kí mình có thể gửi mail để nhận đúng
không mấy ông nhớ về đâu đấy thì thì em
mới bảo là em em thấy là kiểu Em thích
em thích dùng cái Y Vân theo cậu là theo
kiểu như hay hơn Phải bảo Vân ở trong
Mua đồ xong rồi Khi mà sếp thì gọi đến
phải even use xếp như này có cái độc lập
hơn tôi Tôi thích cái ô hơn phải về các
bạn thì water này nó không khác gì một
cái caro cả đầy đủ tính năng thêm giờ
xóa sẽ nằm trong ngày và khai báo nó sẽ
chỉ khai báo một lần theo dõi như này
thì nó sẽ kiểu thay vì tách ra thành
khai báo kiểu như lần theo kiểu như này
cũng chưa
Ừ đấy con sang trường hợp này anh Bởi vì
An Nếu mà chỉ có một cái đúng nghĩa là
chai chỉ một cái thôi Đúng nhỉ vì sau
còn thêm sự kiện ở nhiều nhỉ sự kiện
nhỉ cho sự kiện delete
I Delete với sau xóa rồi thông báo người
dùng à
kiện xếp vi nhà sẽ bao gồm cả sinh ở bao
gồm cả class a xít vậy chứ sự thật là sẽ
bao gồm cả lasted những cả eight rất
thích dùng có shiping à
ở nhà mình sẽ có City lấy từ object lấy
ra được City Cần thiết nó sau đó mình sẽ
lấy đây này
ờ ờ
Ừ từ cách
em nè
chị sẽ Guetta
thì mình sẽ ghét ta lấy à
a copyright
à à
Em hãy để lấy ra được Eros et
ở trong trường hợp mà
da sử có rồi chưa có thì mình vẫn sẽ
kiểm tra thôi mình sẽ là kiểu
có tiền thì á ít
Ừ thì aj City
anh sex chính xác là trong trường này nó
lùn đấy hoặc gà trống gì đó cứ cho bằng
nó bằng chồng như này đi
khi con eo đây là nếu là sự mà có vợ là
có rồi đó ngon ạ
Ừ thì mình sẽ kiểm tra tiếp là chú
ý thêm phát nữa
chị đã kiểm tra bán nếu nó trước tồn tại
ở trong thằng này
a city à chưa tồn tại trong Eros et này
Galaxy ti truyền thêm ICT vào trong như
này
à
à nhưng với điều kiện là cái thằng City
này sẽ phải à
có phải là vì bài đăng bài đăng vẫn có
thể City and Moon mà Và thậm chí là chỗ
ấy nhiều mà đúng ạ Mấy ông nhớ không ạ
Mình sẽ xecro ngay đã
anh như thế vẫn ở chợ Ngọc Lập như này
xử lý nó hơi bị rừng già nghỉ tí sự bị
đoạn này nó ra phết
ở đâu để xem à
tình yêu nó là trống
Ừ đợi tí đợi tí Dạo này lôgic của tôi
đang hơi bị loạn rồi à
a City lấy ra này không ạ
ô t có mạ đây này mẹ làm việc giống hết
giống như thằng này thôi mình sẽ
ở lại phối nghe tiếp
em chuyển ở trong như này không có gì cả
thế này
nôn thì mình sẽ có thể cho mặc định nó
bằng
anh bằng mạng ngay để tránh trường hợp
nó theo adel city lúc đầu là không có gì
cả
Giả sử là ông mới tạo bài đăng ông mới
vào trang web chưa có khi kì cả khi này
có thể bị xóa rồi không ạ thì cái mảnh
da gà trống đúng ạ mình sẽ phải tạo màng
chống Nhưng ai
Ừ đúng nhỉ
để tí nữa gửi tin nhắn
vẫn sẽ phải gọi thằng này chị ạ
Ừ đúng rồi mình vẫn sẽ phải gọi thằng
này lấy toàn bộ City về
em hâm thì thảo truyền vào đây chỉ có
mỗi mạng thì mỗi city của thằng mình mới
thế mà
à Vì sao
Ừ đúng rồi bạn này vẫn sẽ gọi đúng không
ai
không thông cảm có ký hiệu này vào đây à
ở đây này giống kiểu Nga
Ừ
rồi này
ạ sau đó đi cập nhật thêm vào Royal City
sau đó thì mình mày cách lưu lại
A Man City nay mình lưu lại
Con Cá Hàn này à
anh tí nhé cái ha mày Sử dụng hơi nhiều
nghe dùng ở chỗ này dùng ở chỗ này
à à
chị sẽ Đây là một cái hấp ơi ở đây sẽ ta
ghét
i-bar City
Âm Nhạc
khi mình chuyển đúng cái này về như thế
à à
anh
cứ mỗi lần mình
vì mình lưu lưu lại thêm một bài đăng
mới mình sẽ lấy City Từ bà đăng đấy mình
cắt chuỗi Sau đó mình sẽ
Nghe danh sách City cũ nếu có nếu có rồi
mình sẽ cập nhật City mới lần lượt từng
City mới và Xong cái thằng cách này thì
mình sẽ lưu lại
Ừ đúng ạ Mình sẽ lưu lại
ở đây đẩy ra Ừ tớ nghĩ lại ổn Đấy thử
nhé
sự tôi sẽ sang bên admin này
ông chủ mới biết được không ạ
À hôm trước chưa đăng nhập à bây giờ
tưởng lưu lượng season anh kiểu gì Chắc
là hết đăng nhập rồi vào đăng nhập xong
rồi đúng không Mày đăng này sẽ tạo thêm
a Company nữa ạ nhập thêm một cái City
nữa City mà không đụng hàng đi Bình
Dương chơi đụng hàng không ạ
Ờ Ờ chắc thế này thêm rồi
Bạn lỗi gì mà mình còn không biết được
lỗi nó là gì này
lỗi gì đấy
Em dậy chưa
mã lỗi gì nhỉ à
anh em nhé
Em Chừa lại lỗi
anh không biết lỗi gì luôn à
am in sang bên phải amin này
á nhon
How to ngọn nhảy đây nè
bộ bikini Jackson
À mà quên không trả với max ít là sao
Làm gì có hiển thị lỗi được không ạ
hôm trước mình chưa sửa lại cái này mình
sẽ phải object 2
anh không không ạ autok 2
thông báo là kiểu chất rắn báo cô này
không được Tại luôn tôi phải loạt lại
cái Tab nữa
Ừ cái nó gợi ý các thứ nữa
đây sẽ là được rồi
ờ ờ
Anh tốt là 1
các hợp chất hay
anh alo không còn khóc quên quên quên
quên office2 em chưa gặp này mình sẽ à
language này
Ừ Vậy tí nhá
này tế thực tế là một là ông tạo một
thằng mua đồ để ông làm xử lý như thế
này
à À đúng rồi đúng rồi chưa chuyện nó
thích hay phải bên này nữa nếu đã nói là
một là ông làm thì cậu dạng như này
crash như thế này hay là ông có thể dùng
cái ông gọi đến chính via sừng ship của
thằng
Ê thằng à
em hết rồi
có thể tạo dựa theo đúng cái hàng VSIP
này nó sẽ là
bởi vì ông kiểu gì cũng sẽ có tốt hay đi
đây đúng không Thì nó sẽ lôgic nó sẽ như
thế này
ờ ờ
cho thuê ship ngon Lysine ship à
Ừ ông ông khởi tạo ngày lưu lại
Ừ Đợi thì đợi thế chỉ với ông cái này
Ừ thôi trước của tôi dùng cái răng
Attack kiểu nhà để truyền dữ liệu vào
Đợi tí nữa chị nhé nó một và thì nó sẽ
bao gồm mà nó web này
many-to-many contact này
cả hai có nhiều lắm Huế tôi cứ ngồi Tìm
mấy cái Hàn này cho nó ngâu
bộ phim sex đời đi ở Aptech đẩy mạnh lưu
lại
Ồ tôi định nó như này nhá
Anh định nói như này tất cả từng
language này đúng không
nhà thuốc sẽ gọi đến thằng
language này
mới cho nó
anh như này
Ừ mình đây sẽ có là à
cho nó biết đi đúng không ạ
ở đây dow và mình đã thêm đâu
Ừ vậy thì nhất ở tí nhé á
a language
em không thích này mình cập nhật lúc nào
nhỉ
vì vậy language còn gì nhỉ
em tắt đi
thấy bị nhầm rồi
mình sẽ lên language ID nè đấy
Vì sao phải language mình chuyển lên này
để chứng tỏ qua đây cho nhầm rồi
chị
sẽ phải language like
thì mình sẽ là
chưa Nếu mà chưa mình thêm vào thì phát
à à
a a clip này
bộ phim sex kiểm tra là nêm theo đúng
cái language truyền vào đấy
thế này
Ừ để sau đó mình sẽ có mình tạo được hài
rồi Ngon Sau đó mình sẽ có object
Cô mang quýt này
em hết giống như vừa rồi đi
đi làm không Không dùng theo cậu dạng
của ngày cho đỡ khó hiểu nữa mình làm
thuần đi
Ừ mình ở đây mình sẽ truyền vào là
Anh check ID tức à bài đăng này đúng
không ạ
language and sẽ là language gọi để ID
này trông nữa
Ừ cái tôi đang cân nhắc thời vụ là
Office 2 này này là mình sẽ phải truyền
thay cho nó nên là dùng cái hàm tách này
ra tiện với nó sẽ truyền hay được vào
hay xin à truyền hay được báo thay mình
ngôi ngược thủ công nó kiểu
thì nó phải nhập là đầy đủ nói như này
mấy ông ạ sẽ mua đồ nha mày post ngay cơ
hội không thích gõ kiểu thủ công nhớ ai
trong nó hơi bị tối nghĩa mà không thấy
Gọi class được nghỉ đợi két lại nhé
A Gọi class có ra như thế nào nhỉ
ốp lát
cái kiểu Kiều Nga
xe Tesla
Ừ ừ ừ
thế được
ừ ừ
à à
anh nghe có phải được
các tổ mấy hôm trước đi xuất cái ô che
quagsire
anh alo Tải lại cái này đó ok rồi này
anh Hải có Bình Dương này ông ạ
a bear xanh ở bên cái trang sang bên
trang ah
Em sang bên trang áp đi cần này nó phải
thêm cái bình dương
anh có em thấy Sino
sina nghĩa là
anh em thấy là nó vẫn bốn câu truy vấn
thôi nó không hề truy vấn thêm cái City
ở
vì nó không hề khi vẫn thêm city Mày
không Để ý kỹ không ạ
vì nó không hề truy vấn thêm City ở đây
Tại sao có gì em mình lấy từ trong cách
rồi mà mình lấy từ phong cách lúc nào mà
mình lấy được Tức là lúc mà mình khi
mình à
mình cập nhật thế Cái Xếp Hình này
anh access việc chứ Theo mình lưu lưu
lại xong được mua đồ thành công rồi ông
ạ thì mình truyền City vào trong cái
cách đấy thì mình lưu lại nhưng mà trong
cách đấy ông ạ
em gà Tôi thích đặt tên Hàn rồi nói lên
quan đến kết thì tôi sẽ là tên hàng là
ghét
and cách thì nó sẽ hợp lý hơn này à
Ừ tao nó sẽ hiểu thôi đấy
chỉ mình cách có lại rồi xử lý kiểm tra
là nó không hề nằm trong các mạng đấy
mình thêm kể Bình Dương vào trong đấy
rồi mình mặc định mình yêu lại thêm vào
da nó sẽ có thêm Ok chưa
gì ngon ngon đúng không ạ
ê ê
à à
[âm nhạc]
cho tôi bây giờ Bây giờ thì mình sẽ làm
là mỗi khi mình tích và dạo này đâu ạ
thì mình sẽ cần là nó lại xa thì mình
kiểu đẩy lên tìm kiếm chẳng hạn thế
ô Tìm kiếm ở đây là mình sẽ tìm kiếm
những cái bài đăng
ở những cái bạn ạ bài đăng thuộc cái
City đấy nhưng mà vẫn phải nhìn đĩa đầy
đủ tất cả City đúng không ạ
thì nó sẽ có 2 kiểu gà có hai kiểu đấy
một kiểu là mấy ông chơi theo cơ chế là
cẩu
ừ ừ
Ê mấy ông chơi cơ chế kiểu đấy Tìm City
tìm kiểu dạng là tìm Hà Nội và Tim Hồ
Chí Minh cùng một lúc đó cậu à cái chóp
đấy phải vừa có Hà Nội vừa có Hồ Chí
Minh nhưng nghe này Thực ra thử Thế thì
thực ra hơi buồn cười ngoại thì thế nên
là tôi nghĩ là tìm xong
khi họ vẫn liệt kê đầy đủ tất cả City để
mình thì bỏ tích cả cũng như là có thể
dù cho có thể kiểu bọ tích hay là tích
vào cái khác
đề thivật tích và cái khác thì nó sẽ tìm
hai
nghĩa là que in luôn trong về danh sách
đấy chứ không có trường hợp là kiểu là
bắt buộc là chóp đấy phải nằm trong cả
hai có ý nghĩa như thế
Ê mày không chỉ vậy thôi không khi tích
vào hai cái City ở đây này thì nó sẽ là
kiểu mình một ở Hà Nội hay Hồ Chí Minh
chứ không phải là nhóm đấy phải vừa Hà
Nội vừa Hồ Chí Minh cái kiểu như thế
ạ bây giờ sự tích vào đúng không Thì
mình sẽ cần làm mình bắt sự kiện thì sẽ
bắt sự kiện à
Em nạp kiểu như thế nào
Anh có bao lâu rồi đúng không chuyện à
City vào trong người ta luôn này à
Ừ
mình tích thì mình
nhà mình có thể là điều hướng truyền
thêm mà để tôi xem
cho thằng này cũng được
áo phao mẹ lúc này nó khi hòa vào mình
chưa cơ chế Là Mình Cứ mình mình chơi
tôi chỉ đơn giản là mình cứ kiểu mì cơ
chọn hết cái này sao mình ấn nút Peter
thì mới bắt đầu bơi lọc cũng được cho nó
dễ nó làm Cứ chờ đấy đơn giản hơn
Ừ đợi tí nhá đây tôi có một cái nữa
I fall trước đi Tôi sẽ có một cái form
ôm hết toàn bộ tất cả hàng ngày sẽ nằm
đây một cái phone này
là sự tôi cứ làm khu chế cho cậu lại
người dùng Bấm cái nút đi
thật sự thế thì sẽ có cái lát ở đây này
là bước chân này có tên là
Đây à nút đang để nó sẽ là kiểu dạng là
nút cậu nay âm nậu màu sẽ kiểu này
ở ngã ba tuần rau xong rồi bật tuần rau
đúng này
nữa Chả thế
thế này thể y này
thế này sẽ flash này
nhé à
ô kính lúp tiếng Anh là gì nhỉ tự như
mình quên kính lúp rồi à
à à
anh không
có micro arcana
a-ma-dôn icon chat
không có
à à
ở hà Nó tên là sốt thôi
thì nó sẽ giúp E
à à
Chắc ba nó không có vậy
em bị lừa làm nó dễ quá rồi giờ sự tích
và cái này shop này
à À quên mọi chuyện nên thằng này nữa
mình sẽ lên thằng này là City ngày được
hạ
à à
sự tích hoa tích lan
chỉ có mình sẽ truyền City lên nhưng ai
bắt buộc đây sẽ là mạc có thể truyền
được nhiều ngoặc ok
em thay đồ rồi đấy mình có thể tích tích
vào nhà truyền lên số đó thì mình sẽ bắt
ở đây là nếu mà
ưu
điểm mà mình chọn cái City nào đúng
không ạ Mình sẽ truy quét ở đây
a very well
bắt ở đây là City
A là
I speak
ngày đúng ạ
anh vẫn rất thích lớp dễ bị nhầm cái này
quay về rồi
mình sẽ
ở đây Tôi đặt tên nó sẽ nên ta à
sẽ City ở
ở Tây Ninh như đàn
a filter
nhưng mà khi đặt tên biến như thế này nó
cần phân biệt với cái bên này
ờ ờ
sản xuất xuất City
mình sẽ ra
ở KizCiti Hà nằm trong cái Stoke City
Ừ thì mình sẽ
ảnh
chế cực nhạy
a minute
ở đó
trò chuyện lạ
Ừ đúng rồi nhỉ
à à quên quên quên quên à
là mảng trống này để tránh báo lỗi này
em
thích cái này thích ở đây này Nó sẽ
truyền lên là mạnh Nếu không Để ý kỹ nó
làm mạnh như này
chú chó ngon chưa xin chào chị chưa đó
ạ sau đó Thì bây giờ mình sẽ chỉ kiểm
tra là Ê bà với tiết kiệm là kiểu
Em chỉ cần City thằng ấy đoạn bạn này nó
hơi bị dị một tí
cho tất cả sao đoạn này nhá như tôi đã
bảo thì cái City
I still mình chuyển lên Hà Nội đúng
không ạ Ở Hà Nội Hồ Chí Minh không ạ ạ
thôi là sự tôi chưa lên đây mỗi Hà Nội
thôi chẳng hạn như này thì mình sẽ chỉ
cần que cái City nằm trong cái à like
bằng luôn cái Hà Nội là được bằng nó về
Hà Nội là được không ạ Nhưng mà nếu hoặc
giả sử là Hà Nội Hoặc nếu mà cái bài
đăng bao gồm cả Hà Nội và Hồ Chí Minh
như này thì sao thì rõ ràng mấy ông thấy
được là đó là mình phải sửa lại đoạn này
đó là gì
thì mình sẽ đây sẽ sinh City đi
à Tôi đang muốn à
Anh có bao nhiêu thằng ở bao nhiêu hàng
sốt ở đây thì mình sẽ like theo đúng cái
City ạ like cả Hà Nội luôn
Vì
thế tôi sẽ ở đây tôi thường sẽ ghi kiểu
câu truy vấn sẽ đến nay
tôi chưa gọi đến với tenas Vội tôi sẽ là
ít
Ừ nếu mà không trống cái Shop city như
này
chú chó thì tôi sẽ chạy vòng lọc Tok về
xơ City at Sea
ở Shop city ngay chẳng hạn
sau đó đi cô Perry của tôi sẽ que
a Where hiểm một phen à
à mà không khóc chỉ đợi tí nhá Được thôi
một tí phải như này nói chuẩn này were
này nó mới đúng này
him away ngày không phải luôn có lit ơn
nhá
ở Shop city như này thành lập phonghai
I will let our Games
em là ai này
Em vào phần trăm phần trăm này
à à
e100 này
ạ sau đó đi tên đôla quy này
à à
bằng que di
gọi fishnet này đó nó sẽ như này cơ
anh sẽ lăng nhăng như này
câu truy vấn như này nha nếu mà
cô có shit sốt City chuột lên này đúng
thì mình sẽ chạy vòng lặp
gì và tại sao tự nhiên tôi phải có whey
ngoài cùng như này bởi vì nếu mà ông
Noah từng trường hợp thì Owen này có thể
nó sẽ bị lẫn vào cái chỗ què chỗ khác
nên tôi phải có whey ngoài cùng người ôm
tất cả đoạn này như này
Ừ nó mới lăng nhăng ngay Và thậm chí có
thêm cả trường hợp cuối nữa là tôi bảo
rồi Nếu mà City đó vào là nun thì tất cả
lắm chị ạ là có thể nó có nhiều nên
Thành A mình sẽ phải orwell phát quấy
nữa là Ori đây này
ăn shit out nun ngay được City ngày nữa
cờ đó vẽ City Nếu là lùn thì hoàn toàn
được đây không có suy nghĩ nhiều nhé
Đúng rồi nghe đâu rồi
vì thế nó sẽ chạy cho được à cả ở Hà Nội
hay các thứ thôi nhé
ô tô tại trang này mấy ông thầy đó à lùn
nó vẫn ra không ạ Không còn cái nào ở Hồ
Chí Minh nữa đúng ạ
anh đúng không làm thêm mà
xóa này đi này sẽ có cả Bình Dương là Hồ
Chí Minh Hà Nội Hà Nội đông ạ
ở Hồ Chí Minh Hà Nội Thích bài này
ở Hồ Chí Minh Hà Nội mất cái Bình Dương
rồi
Em về chưa Chị chưa ngon Cốt nó sẽ đi
này nó Cốt nó sẽ như này mình sẽ kiểu
truyền lên cái mảnh Sau đó mình sẽ like
theo cái đấy và đương nhiên vẫn có
trường hợp là nếu Man City là trống như
thế này vẫn được chấp nhận với cta trống
thì có thể nó ở rất nhiều nôi nó kiểu
làm thấy mốt đấy nó không thoải mái
không có trọng
Ok chưa
Ừ hi vọng đoạn này ông mấy ông thấm được
ờ ờ
ạ đoạn này không nghĩa và hôm nay tôi
cốt khá là liền mạch không Cốt không bị
kiểu dạng là cậu khó hiểu lắm
dự báo mới nhưng mà nó không hẳn khó
hiểu lắm nó liền mạch họ nếu thấy cốt
cốt để lâu xịt lên đấy đúng không ạ Đấy
là cho để buổi sau đi bố mày Cha chỉ đến
mức để đoạn này thôi đã tải từng tí một
thôi đã không ạ
về làm việc với cách này để hiển thị ra
đến nay này con gì nha mình sẽ tổng kết
lại nhá dùng đi khắp tổng kết lại đi
sẽ đánh giá sau mỗi buổi bằng kỹ thật
nhưng ai tập kết lại mày thì đi 5 này
thêm cái này
thì mình sẽ cậu
em sửa lại cái đoạn khi mà
để lưu lại Office Project language này
không ạ
ở đây City
Ừ rồi
cho mình thì mình biết được thêm đoạn là
bắt sự kiện thì mà
Ừ cái xếp này sẽ bao gồm cả Insert và
update mỗi tội là Delete thì nó sẽ không
gọi đến thôi gà mình thích thì mình phải
bắt thêm Delete để mình xóa thật City
nữa nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là
Ừ chắc nào chưa người phải hiếm trường
hợp phải hiếm
đây có một có mỗi một cái pass liên quan
đến thành phố Bình Dương ạ nhận đầu tư
Xóa Thế Thành phố Bình Dương thì đúng là
nó không cập nhật lại cách này đúng à
khi bây giờ sửa có xóa bài đang đấy rồi
tôi xơ mỗi Bình Dương thì đúng là không
ta thật ông ạ
về ạ khi mà là nung thì mình sẽ phải
thêm hỏi chấm Để loại bỏ chúng nó phải
đi không ạ cảm thấy set này
kok này
Có ai ở cho bộ Hôm nay thì mới truy cập
nhật thêm được một tí nhưng mà chắc à
một tí đấy cũng tương đối mới dồi nhiều
nó mới đúng không ạ thấy là nó mới
mấy ông thấy à Cái điểm hai cái điểm hay
mà Vừa tôi mới chỉ mấy ông thêm đó là
mình có thể mình tạo ra một cái quay
vici vấn kiểu nhớ ai xong rồi mình sẽ đi
đẻ thêm mỗi mỗi cái câu whey như này hồi
trước tôi còn bị nhầm cơ Tôi cứ tưởng là
tôi phải hiểu Ghi kiểu ngay bằng như này
thì mà hiểu được là câu chuyện mới bằng
con chỉ cần cũ + như thế này mà không
Khi mà gọi như này vẫn chắc là nó ghi đè
thẳng lên chính nó mình sẽ để que Mình
có thể gọi kiểu như này Nếu mà như tôi
đã bảo quay này là quen à hình như nó
thì đè lên nhưng không cần bôi trơn thì
vậy Nhờ quen thì đúng cần Western Ware
thì như cần biết ơn đấy ạ
anh như thế thuốc xóa đi nha
anh nhìn đúng rồi không cần đi tơ nó dọn
đây chỉ cần thêm thêm ngay được nhưng
woori tấn
Wen thì tớ là sao When tôi thể viết đoạn
này ngắn hơn để đỡ phải dùng ít ngay Nếu
là sự miếu khó chịu được Kiểu như này
thì mấy ông hiền dùng quen nhưng nhưng
cá nhân tôi thích dùng ít hơn bởi vì ở
sao bởi grad này gần như nó khởi tạo
thêm một thằng mới và có sự vấn nó sẽ bị
nặng hơn một tí Ờ
Ừ nhưng mà nếu mà giờ sử dụng mấy ông
muốn thích liền mạch và cốt trong đó xấu
hơn người dùng từ xấu hơn bởi vì rõ ràng
về sau ít kiểu nhảy về các bạn tôi thấy
thương minh hơn à
cái đoạn thử thai cái này bằng word thì
anh sẽ thấy nó như này là quen này và
cái ít mày còn eo được còn quen thì
không Gọi eo đấy còn gì đấy Cái thứ thôi
có chuyện nha
hệt ngày không ạ
à à
A và như tôi bảo weather mình sẽ có gì
trơn không ạ ạ
trùng như này nhưng mà sẽ ra không nên
để chống lại họ tên Quý đồ đi
sau khi mà quen thì ông phải vì Tôn
xe tải thì đoạn này của ông thì sẽ chỉ
còn là họ ngay sau
Ừ thì ông sẽ không phải ít ạ Ông sẽ
không phải ít vì bạn chắc quen này nó là
bằng cả Thấy rồi thì vợ
I eat mày Cái này như này
ừ ừ
chỉ cách viết thì có thể enter xuống
dòng thì nó đỡ hơn một tí như thế này
Em đỡ Hùng Tí nữa này
nó đẹp đấy Cái này không đẹp đấy nhưng
về sau mà mình sửa eo thêm một cái eo
nhỏ nhắn thì cái quen này nó sẽ có tác
dụng luôn cái quần When này chị phù hợp
và Khiêm có ông có một ít thế gần nhất
có ai về sau ông còn như ý thì cái đoạn
quen này nó dài lắm thằng nha À tôi
thích cá nhân tôi vẫn thích dùng cái ít
kiểu thủ công hơn
A và cái quen này nó làm cái á nặng hơn
cái ít anh nhá
Tôi ở cùng xem cái bài so sánh cái tốc
độ xử lý rồi kể quen để khiến cho nó
nặng hơn khi dùng ít thuần được chị ạ
nên là tôi khuya là mấy ông nên dùng ít
hơn cái thay vì dùng quen nhưng mà đông
nhiên là mấy ông sẽ thấy nó hơi bị khó
chịu một tí ông phải tạo một cái thằng
biến trung gian như thế này ông tạ đào
tạo tạo hết đã sôi đến cuối ông mới cho
dán được giá trị như này ngoại đi thôi
thì
Ừ cái này đó là một cái bài toán đánh
đổi giống như cái mà mà về sau làm Sino
nó như thế nghĩa là Shino về sau Cốt nó
sẽ không còn hoàn được đẹp và nó ngắn
gọn giống như là hồi mới học nữa thôi
mới học thì vừa rồi lại ngắn gọn hơn so
với cái ra ngoài nhưng cải tốc độ truy
vấn mà bị giảm đi tốc độ xử lí nó bị
giảm như một tí nên về sau mấy ông lại
phải làm là chấp nhận và cốt là xấu hơn
tí nhưng với tốc độ và nhanh hơn đây cái
ít mà nhanh hơn cái vừa rồi chẳng ạ thậm
chí về sau mấy ông trong một vài trường
hợp ông không nên dùng uruk quân mà ông
phải cốt do cút thuần vì bởi vì bởi vì À
cái đấy nó quá nặng để mà ông biến nó
thành có lesson 2 cái gì đó thậm chiếu
không thuộc về Trần này ông phải sống
cho ai vì nó nặng chẳng ạ gần nhà cũng
hiểu cho thì thì cái đấy bài toán đánh
đổ Vì sao anh ấy
cái hedy này nó miễn phí nên là cá nhân
tôi nghĩ thì chắc chắn nó sẽ không ngon
mà la với cát tường dùng là khi cắt rồi
nhưng mà tôi chưa dùng hết tính năng của
nó còn hay đi này Thực ra tôi thấy là nó
khá đơn giản là chẳng có nhiều tính năng
mấy để mà là gọi là để mạch cậu mò nó nó
hệ nó khá ít thì năng còn nhưng mà bù
lại thì tôi nghĩa là nhân là miễn phí có
ai là nó vẫn nhanh và ngon hơn thằng pê
mai em đi người sẽ hắn rồi Tôi thấy một
trong những cái tiện mà nó nữa đó là
việc cả nó lưu lại những cái mình ở fito
và những cái mình có thể bỏ salad những
cái một vài trường và Seto và nó còn lưu
lại những cái mình là phi tơ nữa sự như
ý em thật sự nhé
bây giờ que 7 ngày nào ạ sẽ lưu lại lịch
sử cũ là đã quen như nào
em hết
vì thế mẹ ông thế chả giờ nhanh ngay đấy
một trong những cái tôi rất thích hồi mà
dùng tép pi máy mini Cứ phải gõ đi Gọi
lại mấy cái thuộc Nitơ có thứ nó khó
chịu
Em hãy còn đây là khá nhanh nhưng cái
thằng này Thực ra là nó hơi bị ngu mày
thì khi mà ông vào cái bảng mà dữ liệu
ý nó sẽ có bao gồm nó luôn order mặc
định order mấy ông thấy cậu chỉ vật nó
tự động chạy đều order rồi lý các thứ
thứ Nên là đôi khi khiến chết luôn để
tao bây giờ thôi Khi mà nó tự động chạy
mình cái này chẳng nào đây
Ừ Tôi phải reset tại cái đấy reset lại
cái này mấy lần khi mà chị vẫn quá nặng
ở trên database ở trên công ty thôi
nó tự động chạy mà tự động chạy lại
những cái câu chuyện cũ ông đã từng chạy
ở cái bảng này
ạ Ông mà tha mắt thì lại nhắn tin riêng
hoặc bình luận nha à
a cho tôi Nghĩa ở thư ca toàn bộ những
cái tôi đang dạy này vì cái đoạn này có
nghĩa là tao cũng ở bên mua đổ được
nhiều có thể nếu có thể
ở bảng hệ thống hợp amono tạm thời mày
có đoạn này vẫn đang ăn còn hôm sau chắc
là tôi sẽ sống dân ở đừng mua đồ bởi vì
cái này nó xử lý qua nên liên quan ra
tầm bậy không phải
mẹ con ăn cơm đi of fan Castle không có
cái đoạn xử lý ngay à
tin nhắn